[Music]
the North Korea dilemma is getting even
more complicated for president Trump now
it looks like both Russia and China had
been secretly shipping oil to North
Korea in violation of the United Nations
sanctions we told you last night how a
US spy satellite photos apparently show
Chinese ships transferring oil to North
Korean ships at sea now two senior
European security sources tell Reuters
that the Russians have been doing the
same thing let's discuss what this means
with Fox News contributor and political
science professor Chiron Skinner in San
Francisco professor thank you so much
for joining us this is a very difficult
situation I mean on one hand you had a
very impressive vote in the United
Nations only now to have evidence that
both Russia and China are violating
these same sanctions what would you
recommend to the president what's
actually happening here is that global
leadership is being devolved to the
United States and because the Russians
and Chinese are not living up to United
Nations Security Council resolutions
especially the one in September they're
violating international law and
international norms and I would suggest
that the president of the United States
make it absolutely clear that if the
governments in Russia and China do not
penalize and stop those shipping
companies that are trading oil with the
North Koreans that the United States has
to begin to look at military options and
that underscore the fact that the United
States is actually going to become the
leader of resolving the North Korean
conflict within North East Asia and
Beyond and that's not something I think
the Russians and the Chinese want to
happen now to add the clarity that
you're seeking a military option against
China and Russia is probably not viable
but they can do some things for instance
such as a naval blockade is that what
you mean by saying taking action and
military action I'm not really
suggesting military action because I
know that the Secretary of State and the
Secretary of Defense do not want to go
down that path they've been working
overtime on the
diplomatic front but we have to let our
strategic adversaries in the North Korea
issue understand that the full range of
options have to be on the table we will
continue to use diplomacy aggressively
but they have to know that if they make
North Korea much more of an unstable
regime by propping it up it serves no
good interest for them as well I don't
think they quite understand it yet now
the president has tried to channel
Ronald Reagan in this whole peace
through strength approach is the United
Nations as worthless as it seems from at
least my vantage point I wouldn't say
it's worthless it is a huge debating
society where often the in the General
Assembly the United States is the target
but the fact that we got unanimous votes
in the United Nations suggests that the
international community is moving in the
direction of what the United States has
been saying all along especially under
President Trump that North Korea has to
be a denuclearized country because it is
so particularly dangerous it could be
the site of nuclear proliferation
throughout Northeast Asia indeed the
indo-pacific region and so I think what
it can do for the United States now
under the America first policy of the
president is help reinforce the issues
that America first imprinted realism a
pillar pillar of the president's policy
suggest is that sovereignty matters that
respecting international norms and laws
they matter as well and so in that way
the UN does play a useful role my own
personal take on this is that more
sanctions is it going to work because
the leader of North Korea really doesn't
care about his people but last question
for you real quick
the idea of a naval blockade to prohibit
the importation of things that are
needed in critical in North Korea do you
believe that is one of the viable things
sitting on the President's desk I think
it's being debated in the Pentagon and
in the national security community
whether it's on the President's desk I
don't know but let me just speak to your
pessimism on UN Security Council
resolutions they do work when there is
compliance and if the given the strict
nature of the most recent December
resolution against North Korea and the
Security Council if indeed it's
implemented fully it has a punishing
impact on the North Korean economy the
Russians and Chinese if they don't
comply they are undermining something
that could really bring North Korea to
the negotiating table well and I do I
hope that President Trump continues to
show the world how the Russians and the
Chinese evidently are not complying was
something that they were supportive of
not too long ago professor we wish you
the happiest of holidays in a happy new
year and thank you again for joining us